something extraordinary happened this
week on the stock market
a david and goliath tale of wealthy
traders
versus internet chat rooms hold hold
hold hold they cannot beat the internet
of small investors on smartphones taking
on wall street
sharks and winning it revolved primarily
around gamestop a video games retailer
struggling to modernize
its stocks were steadily falling the
firm on the brink of collapse
big wall street investors did what they
often do when companies are failing they
bet against gamestop
setting themselves up to make millions
when it went under so far
so normal but in the chat rooms of
reddit small traders had other ideas
they bought shares on mass which caused
the share price to soar seemingly at
odds
with the actual value of the company it
cost wall street their big bets
the impact's been spectacular at its
peak the company was worth over 24
billion pounds
in response some trading apps banned
people buying more stock
creating yet more volatility in the
market for the bedroom-based traders
these are still risky investments
but many aren't worried about losing
money this is about power
not profit oh it's absolutely about
principal it's about sticking it to the
man
that's 100 what it's about what was so
motivating about it
look at someone that's my age you know
i'm 31 years old i graduated out of high
school in 2008 in the uh
great recession and so there's a lot of
built up anger and resentment towards
the system
and honestly it feels like this is a
revolution
and there's outrage at small traders
being banned from more buying by
platforms
uniting the fiercest of political foes
and there's an entire generation
who has had their trust in
government rocked trust in wall street
rocked trading apps have made stocks
more accessible
but experts fear a lot of people with
limited knowledge are causing bubbles
when they burst the poorest will lose
most the fact is look what has happened
with gamestop is crazy i guarantee you
well
i can't be 100 but i'm very confident
that in a couple of months it will be a
lot lower than where it is now
at some point it's going to collapse and
i don't want it to be ordinary people
out there who've invested their
housing deposits or their kids
university tuition
for many this place has always
symbolized inequality
as a recession bites the stock market
still booms
many feel there's a reckoning still to
come hell